[Music]  this thing on  hey miss ponce  if you find this recording  don't feel bad about this  part of the journey is the end  [Music]  just for the record being adrift in  space with zero promise of rescue is  more fun than it sounds  food and water ran out  four days ago  oxygen will run out tomorrow morning  i mean  when i drift off i will dream about you  it's always you  [Music]  [Music]  thanos did  exactly what he said he was gonna do  wiped out  50  of all living creatures  we lost  all of us  we lost friends  we lost family  we lost a part of ourselves  this is the fight of our lives  this is gonna work steve  i know it is  because i don't know what i'm gonna do  if it doesn't  hi uh is anyone home this is scott lang  we met a few years ago at the airport in  germany i got really big is this an old  message ant-man  i know you don't i know you know that  it's the front door that's me can you  buzz me in